[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
consciousness has been in with us for a
long time and we're all very familiar
with our own consciousness I hope but
how do we get a handle on it how can we
explain it is there progress being made
in the neurosciences or in psychology is
the progress being made in philosophy
are there ways in which we might have a
better understanding of what it is where
it came from how it works and how we
explain it or how we accommodate it in
the physical world so these questions
have led to quite a polarized set of
views we have people who on the one hand
think that although neurosciences
chipping away it just needs to continue
and it may take a very long time before
we get any ultimate explanation others
believe perhaps there's no ultimate
explanation that we still want to know
what consciousness does for us what is
what its function is and perhaps even
and find out how it depends a little bit
on our physical makeup but other people
certainly in philosophy have thought the
lack of progress is a sign that we've
structured the debate in the wrong way
and that perhaps the commitment to
materialism is preventing us from seeing
how to give a proper and fulfilling
explanation of how subjectivity fits
into the world and and how we take our
place in that so with me to discuss this
today we have Susan Blackmore who is a
psychologist and an author of several
books the meme machine then more
recently we've had conversations on
consciousness interviewing philosophers
and neuroscientists
she's also producing has produced a new
book seeing myself which explores the
science of out-of-body experiences and
she wanted me to tell you that the third
edition of consciousness and
introduction has just come out we have
got Philip Gogh who is a moment an
associate professor
at the Central European University in
Budapest although he's moving very soon
to the University of Durham in
philosophy his 2017 book consciousness
and fundamental reality defends Pan
psychism and he's also working at the
moment on a wider public book called
Galileo's error a manifesto for the new
science of consciousness and finally we
have Nicholas Humphrey who is a
psychologist who's done pioneering work
into the evolution of intelligence and
consciousness and his books include the
mind made flesh a history of the mind
and soul dust and the magic of
consciousness so I'm going to invite
each of our speakers to give you their
opening initial pitch on the topic
they'll take four minutes each then
we'll have some discussion we'll go into
a few more themes of this session and
then I will close by inviting questions
from you so Phillip perhaps you could
start and give us your four minutes
worth please okay I'll try my best so my
starting point is we know that
consciousness is real nothing is more
evident than the reality of one's own
feelings and experiences and yet nothing
is harder to integrate into our
scientific worldview it's generally
agreed that we don't really have even
the beginnings of an explanation of how
brains produce consciousness this is the
so called hard problem of consciousness
but although this is all these problems
taking very seriously many people argue
that well if you just look at the great
success of physical science in
explaining more and more of our universe
they sought to give us confidence that
if we just plug away and our standard
methods for investing in the brain will
one day so the problem of consciousness
however a problem of consciousness is
radically unlike any of the other
challenges physical sciences ever faced
the problem is that physical science
works with the purely quantitative
had malaria whereas consciousness is an
essentially qualitative phenomenon just
in the sense that it involves qualities
we think about the redness of a red
experience the sweet smell of flowers
the taste of coffee
you simply can't capture these kind of
qualities in the purely quantitative
language of physical science and indeed
this point was well understood by the
founder of physical science namely
Galileo
so Galileo never intended physical
science to be a complete description of
reality he hoped that it could deal with
the mathematical features of reality but
he took it for granted that it couldn't
capture the qualities of consciousness
which he took to reside in the soul and
moreover I've argued that the reason
physical science has done so well is
because from the start galileo kicks
things off by taking consciousness out
of its domain of inquiry so he gave
physical scientists a more manageable
task so these people who say oh no
physical science has gone really well
it'll one day explain consciousness my
responses it's gone really well
precisely because it was never designed
for that purpose so what about dualism
the view that consciousness is a
property of the immaterial soul outside
of the physical body and brain
unfortunately this view is also hopeless
in my view I think contemporary
neuroscience gives us an incredibly
strong evidence that consciousness is in
the brain rather than the soul so what
we're gonna do when I studied philosophy
and the dying embers of the 20th century
we were taught that these are the only
two options you either think physical
science will explain it in which case
you're a materialist or you think it's
non-physical in which case you do list
fortunately there is a middle way the
view known as punt psychism so rather
than try to explain consciousness in
terms of utterly non conscious brain
processes as we've been trying to do
very little success for many decades now
the pun psychist aspires to explain the
complex consciousness of human and
animal brains in terms of simpler forms
of consciousness simpler forms of
consciousness which are postulated to
exist as basic features of the matter as
basic properties of fundamental
particles so the view feels a bit wacky
a bit new-age but you know I
we should review on it's not on its
cultural associations but on its
explanatory power what pun psychism
offers us is a way of integrating
consciousness into our scientific
picture of the world and it does so in a
way that avoids the deep problems
associated both with physics both with
materialism and with dualism and for
that reason I think at the very least
it's a position we should take very
seriously indeed thanks Philip good
opening pitch Nick would you like to
take on there yes Philip thanks for that
introduction cause it I think you're
absolutely right we need to start by
considering the problem of phenomenal
consciousness of the qualities of
experience but if like me you're sure
that the brain is actually responsible
for producing them then their answer the
question which we were originally posed
can we explain it by examining the brain
I think the answer must in principle be
yes I'm quite sure all the different
scientists were clever enough then by
examining then in what's going on in my
brain right now he or she could in
principle deduce what it's like to be me
at this moment but the problem is of
course that no one is a clever enough to
do that or no we're very far from being
able to deduce consciousness from the
brain so that way of approaching it is I
think a non-starter so the question is
where should we start if not with
neuroscience well I agree with Philip
that we must start with the experience
itself and the phenomenal feel of
consciousness the what it's like to see
read or to feel pain or to taste salt
and we must decide exactly how best to
characterize that experience these
amazing phenomena both subjectively and
so far as possible objectively what are
they leading us to do in the world which
we can look at in measure but then
rather than going straight to the brain
because I think that's wrong way we need
to start theorizing we've got to come up
with some theoretical model which
explains how a physical mechanism of any
kind could in principle the lever
consciousness as we've decided we want
to describe it now I'm not saying that's
going to be easy
in fact we immediately run
against what seems to be an insuperable
problem Phyllis has mentioned it for
surely we won't be describing
consciousness correctly unless we
recognize that it is indeed somehow
immaterial out of this world the
essential feature of consciousness is
that it's like something that couldn't
be delivered by a physical brain as
Colin McGinnis colorfully put it the
brain is just the wrong kind of thing to
give birth to consciousness you might as
well assert that numbers emerge from
biscuits or ethics from rhubarb so well
what should we then do well maybe just
as Phillips has been recommending we are
simply going to have to move the goal
posts and redefine what we mean by a
physical mechanism if we can't get
consciousness from unconscious physical
elements elements as we usually think of
them then maybe yeah I have to say that
the elements are a little bit conscious
to start with or to go back to rhubarb
and or to biscuits and numbers if we
can't get numbers from a numeral this
gets as we know them then biscuits must
be a little bit normally to start with
that's to say that we are going to take
the route of simply postulating the
existence at a small scale of the very
thing were trying to expand
[Applause]
[Music]